[Musique]
bienvenue si vous nous rejoignez pas la
deuxième partie on est très nombreux là
j'ai jamais vu autant de monde en face
de moi incroyable toujours avec nos
chroniqueurs Isabelle Morini boss Damien
Canivez notre invité aujourd'hui Elodie
Gossuin qui sort ce bouquin c'est génial
pour toutes les mamans pour toutes les
familles pour tous les ados pour tous
les enfants on vous le recommande
vivement Gauthier de moi de nous a
rejoint bonsoir
alors Gauthier
c'est un spécialiste de la politique on
va parler de la bouille entre Nicolas
Sarkozy et François Hollande ils sont
envoyés la balle ça le coup de petites
piques à droite à gauche un nouvel
épisode exactement
Jean-Michel Cohen est avec nous on va
parler
de l'alimentation discount
est-ce que c'est bien n'en dites pas
plus on va en parler dans un instant ah
gros suspense j'espère que vous allez
dire oui parce que franchement on a tous
du mal à remplir nos caddie alors on va
commencer par la tendance politique si
ça vous va Elodie on va revenir sur une
flash non ça vous va pas ah mais vous
allez adorer le dit vous allez adorer le
clash parce que ça fait des années que
ça dure je parle souvent de contrôle
hein
il y a eu plusieurs épisodes je rappelle
quand même que en 2005 il faisait la Une
de Paris Match ensemble pour la
Constitution européenne et le référendum
donc on est vraiment effectivement très
loin de cet épisode et voilà une
campagne présidentielle entre temps et
un débat présidentiel célèbre ah oui oui
avec le moi président d'ailleurs vous
allez le voir vous allez voir dans les
petites piques qui se sont envoyées
puisque ce matin Nicolas Sarkozy on a
renvoyé une à François Hollande qui
s'exprimait hier vous allez voir il a
repris un peu le mois président
on va le voir on va voir cet extrait il
était invité hier
président de la République je ne
m'abaisserai pas à m'en prendre un bon
prédécesseur et je crois que là il y a
un niveau de dignité à voir je comprends
c'est très difficile d'être battu c'est
une douleur parce que c'est la blessure
d'orgueil mais voilà je veux pas en
rajouter je pense que ça a été
suffisamment cruel en 2007
franchement
ça c'est assez fou
il dit je l'attaque pas il l'attaque
quand même après effectivement il y a eu
plusieurs épisodes parce que Nicolas
Sarkozy pourquoi il l'a fait parce qu'on
le fait réagir à des propos rapportés
dans Le Parisien ou Nicolas Sarkozy a
déjeuné avec des députés les
républicains où il dit qu'il méprise
François Hollande et où il raconte que à
chaque fois qu'il croise François
Hollande il lui dit tiens tu as pris un
kilo au bout d'un moment effectivement
c'est vrai
et c'est la réponse qu'il a faite à
François Hollande puisque François
Hollande pourquoi tu me dis ça à chaque
fois qu'on se croise et il lui a répondu
effectivement parce que c'est vrai
Nicolas Sarkozy ce matin on a remis une
couche
depuis 1958 avoir été président de la
République bon et allez je vais même
faire une confidence alors c'est quand
même plus agréable pour moi de parler
avec Monsieur Macron qu'avec un autre
président de la République on va pas
donner le nom c'est ça
Emmanuel Macron
[Applaudissements]
quelque chose qui a vraiment vexé
Nicolas Sarkozy c'est la passation de
pouvoir parce que
la voiture Nicolas et Carla Bruni
Sarkozy et où il est rentré dans
l'Élysée pour actionner le moment où il
allait être investi président de la
République il y a ça et puis Nicolas
Sarkozy et son entourage ont toujours
soupçonné François Hollande d'avoir
monté un cabinet noir quand il était à
l'Élysée pour l'affaiblir d'un point de
vue judiciaire incroyable quand même ça
donne une image de deux présidents enfin
deux anciens présidents franchement
alors nous ça nous fait un peu sourire
mais bon deux anciens présidents qui se
renvoient des pics comme ça à longueur
de temps c'est c'est ça donne quelle
image je sais pas comment envoyer ça ça
donne une assez mauvaise image mais en
attendant on voit le public quand on
regarde ces images là et on rigole et
d'ailleurs Nicolas Sarkozy a le sourire
aussi quand il balançait le pic là donc
je sais pas si il y a une vraie
détestation sincère c'est plutôt quelque
chose d'assez cordialement
qui se déteste vraiment
il se déteste
ce matin vous l'aviez vu oui je pense
franchement que ce soit en creux ou que
ce soit dans ce qui est dit franchement
il ne l'aime pas ça mais en revanche
c'est ce qu'on appelle le jeu politique
quand on regarde les bouquins de
l'histoire ou le politique contemporaine
on retient c'est vrai les petites
phrases et les deux de ce point de vue
là sont super doués pour ça quoi qu'on
en dise pour les fameux punchlines mais
c'est vrai qu'ils sont rarement d'accord
sur certains points c'est à dire sur le
nucléaire ils sont pas d'accord sur la
statue de l'Ukraine en Europe mais là
c'est personnel c'est au-delà des
divergences politiques c'est personnel
d'habitude ils arrivent au-delà du
clivage partisan et eux ils arrivent pas
du tout à se rapprocher mais là il
s'entendent pas mais il faut il
s'entendent pas pour de vrai je pense
mais il faut savoir que moi en
travaillant comme ça dans les émissions
j'ai découvert que parfois c'était des
fausses des fausses tension par exemple
un Gabriel Attal et un jardin de mardea
ça dort je les ai vu en train de se
boire un petit Kawa euh
j'étais parti
ça dort et se respecte quand vous
croisez quelqu'un vous avez beau faire
un débat avec lui si vous n'avez pas une
animosité profonde et des divergences
personnelles vous êtes capable de lui
serrer la main de boire un café je sais
que quand sur une chaîne info il y a
Mathilde Panou qu'un jour qui avait
refusé de serrer la main de Jordan
Bardella parce que elle veut pas serrer
la main du rassemblement national c'est
quand même l'exception c'est à dire que
en les politiques peuvent se respecter
même s'ils sont en désaccord voilà
effectivement ça nous fait sourire mais
c'est un peu pathétique et par rapport à
l'image que ça renvoie c'est pire que
nos propres enfants à l'école dans la
cour de récré je pense que en terme
d'image pour notre pays on mérite mieux
que ça quoi moi je trouve mes Gauthier a
raison c'est vrai que le raccompagne
l'histoire de non raccompagner le
président sortant à sa voiture moi
honnêtement ça m'avait beaucoup choqué
je trouve que c'était un manque des gars
et puis un manque protocolaire tout
simplement c'était une déclaration de
guerre et après depuis effectivement il
change de pique permanent entre les deux
à chaque fois dès qu'ils en ont
l'occasion on observe parce que des fois
ils sont réunis pour des cérémonies
officielles en tant que ancien président
donc on observe toujours la poignée de
main les les regards et parfois oui on
capte une certaine tension mais oui
c'est c'est sûr que ça va continuer il y
a aucune raison que ça s'arrête plus
entre les deux et ça marche bien on
parle on parle de l'un comme on parle de
l'autre mais vraiment ce qui est ce qui
est incroyable avec François Hollande
encore une fois c'est la manière qu'il a
de le faire je ne vais pas attaquer
l'ancien président parce que moi je suis
au dessus mais après pas j'attaque quand
même
est-ce que c'est pas lié au fait que les
deux serait encore quelque part un
destin au sommet moi je pense qu'ils
sont revenus tous les deux parce qu'ils
ont ils ont réessayé tous les deux et
ils ont échoué tous les deux Nicolas
Sarkozy il a échoué à la primaire de sa
famille politique alors qu'il avait été
président de la République et François
Hollande il a essayé le coup précédent
Julien Dray a même essayé de voilà qui
est un très proche de lui de lui à
essayer de voilà de possibilité de
retour et ça n'a pas du tout fonctionné
Jean-Michel tout ça la politique les
petites phrases à disco pendant 25 ans
donc je connais ce monde là
c'est tout à fait exact ça veut dire que
quelques Jean-Michel vous avez fait de
la politique 25 ans vous faisiez quoi
bah j'étais élu à Boulogne j'ai été à un
moment donné proche de Sarkozy j'ai
connu Hollande et je peux dire que la
politique
consulter
justement
alors là c'est ma fierté il ne m'a
jamais consulté j'observe d'ailleurs que
Sarkozy avec qui j'avais à qui j'avais
donné quelques conseils il se maintient
plutôt pas mal et de l'autre côté ça
dérape mais je pense que oui ce jeu de
détestation il est normal et qu'en fait
l'un comme l'autre ils ont quand même en
arrière-penser la possibilité que on
peut toujours revenir bien sûr a priori
il y a peu de chances mais si jamais ça
le faisait j'irais bien manger un peu à
l'Élysée
où il a des mots assez dur sur François
Hollande encore une fois décidément oui
c'est possible je vois pas pourquoi ça
s'arrêterait je vois pas pourquoi ça
s'arrêterait étant donné qu'ils ne
peuvent pas se voir l'un l'autre dès
qu'ils ont l'occasion de se tirer dessus
ils le font donc oui je vois pas
pourquoi ça s'arrête là
c'est pas au programme
qui jouait Nicolas Sarkozy et Grégory
Gadbois qui jouait François Hollande qui
s'appelait président au pluriel et qui
était assez marrant de ce point de vue
là de cette détestation qui se trouve
Nicolas Sarkozy avait dit en interview
Jean Dujardin c'est moi et c'est pas
François Hollande oui je préfère qu'il
soit aujourd'hui jardin qui m'interprète
plutôt Grégory gagboet et encore une
fois il avait fait référence au poids de
François Hollande comme ça
sympa voilà donc pour cette séquence
amoureuse on aura certainement d'autres
on va faire attention aux Gautier vous
allez regarder effectivement avec nous
des petites séquences comme ça